the family of a moped Rider killed in a
DUI crash pleading for change the now
convicted driver who had a previous DUI
could spend as little as six years in
prison now they want to know why the man
who killed their brother couldn't be
charged with murder it is a story the 8
News investigators have been looking
into for months tonight what we found in
the case that's legally referred to as
an accident we do want to warn you the
video you are about to see may be
graphic
thank you
Andrew Rodriguez tells a police officer
he accidentally just killed a man my
birthday weekend and have you had
anything to drink tonight yeah yeah
Rodriguez was in Las Vegas from Texas on
this June evening to celebrate tonight
wouldn't be his first DUI he faced a
similar charge in 2015. put your feet
together arm got your thought okay but
now in June 2021 he had no license and
was behind the wheel of this Lamborghini
a car rented to someone else this is how
a police officer reacted to seeing that
mangled vehicle for the first time
the crash site on Russell Road looked
more like an explosion than a collision
pieces of metal in human remains spread
across several Lanes of traffic police
would later learn Rodriguez was driving
drunk at 100 141 miles an hour before
colliding with a moped riding on it was
58 year old Walter Anderson known as Jay
just demolished a human being Joan
Anderson Shelley and Antoinette Alderman
are Anderson Sisters their brother a
cook at Denny's just driving home after
his shift was split in two these
markings show where police found pieces
of his body he's not a statistic he
wasn't an animal he was a human being a
human being a brother a father a son
killed in an instant who goes down one
of our streets
going 141 miles an hour in a 45 what did
you think was going to happen the
sisters say they became concerned when
they learned Jay didn't come to work the
next day by Monday afternoon the coroner
was asking for them to describe their
brother's scars at this point okay
you're being placed under arrest for DUI
there are four kitten Seekers
prosecutors later charged him with DUI
resulting in death the harshest penalty
Nevada law allows the statute carries a
prison sentence of 2 to 20 years
Rodriguez took a plea deal sending him
to prison for at least six he still gets
to live in jail and he gets to
eventually come out and be with his
family at a reckless feed like that and
DUI it's murder but the law says it's
not I equate somebody's choice to drive
140 miles an hour under the influence of
alcohol
to one of the highest levels of criminal
Behavior Clark County district attorney
Steve Wolfson has tried to charge DUI
drivers who kill a person on the road
whose speed and who drive with no care
for another person's life would murder
this is a person who made a choice to
drive this way but the Nevada Supreme
Court says that's illegal a 2020 ruling
striking down prosecutors attempts in a
case of a speeding intoxicated driver
who killed a man the justice is writing
although malice may be inferred Nevada
has laws for cases of non-intentional
vehicular homicide and prosecutors may
not charge defendants with second-degree
murder for a death resulting from
driving Under the Influence very sorry
wow it was an accident Andrew Rodriguez
apologized to Anderson's family before
going to prison for what is officially
ruled an accident an accident is going
50 miles an hour 55 miles an hour in a
45 and hitting somebody that's an
accident
demolishing murdering someone is exactly
what you did it's just got to stop but
how does it stop and who wants to step
up to help stop it that's the issue
right there the Anderson family hopes
Nevada lawmakers either increase
penalties or allow for deaths like Jays
to be classified as murder he used a
vehicle that was his murder weapon
Andrew Rodriguez who told police in that
video that he has a young child will be
up for parole in six years that is in
2028 a judge ordering him to have a
device put on his car preventing him
from driving impaired for several years
whenever he gets out of prison